[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club ten of Africa's
greatest chess players compete in
Abidjan as Vivendi presents the 2018
cote d'ivoire
rapid and glitz Invitational
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for day two's coverage of the 2018
cote d'ivoire rapid and blitz
invitational my name is Ben Simon joined
as always by Grandmaster Robert hun
gaskey and yesterday wasn't a runaway
train as we thought it might be things
are still a little bit equal in the
field Robert yeah not at all I mean we
were expecting a mean to just blow
through the field and that's not what
happened I mean at the end of the day we
had a three-way tie for first place and
I mean wasn't part of it absolutely now
let's take a look at the players that
are in this event before we look at some
games that have already happened earlier
today ten players ten nations
represented some of the best players in
all of Africa you can see based on feet
a rating there on the left column three
of the top ten players on the continent
are here in well not here here but in
the Ivory Coast on the Ivory Coast
playing in this rapid and blitz event
the universal rating system will be
referenced in this event which is quite
topical because it is a rapid in blitz
event the universal rating system of
course covers gameplay in all time
controls the format is as follows so we
are in the rapid phase right now
game in 25 with a 10-second delay the
players are playing three rounds a day
and that means after three days they
will have completed a full round-robin
each game is worth two points you get
one point for it draw zero points for a
loss and today of course day two of
rapid tomorrow is day three of rapid and
then Dave born day five will consist of
blitz a full round-robin each day the
time control is game in five minutes
with a three second delay no increment
in this tournament it's a double
round-robin affair each game is worth
one point and that's to put it in line
with the rapid you see that the rapid
games are weighted and we'll finish this
up on Saturday and Sunday with blitz and
now let's take a look at the standings
after five rounds of rapid have been
played keep in mind this tournament
began several hours ago in Abidjan in
on the Ivory Coast and they have played
five rounds each game has been worth two
points and we have a tie at the top
Robert what do you what do you make of
these standings so far well I'm very
impressed with some of the lesser-known
names you could say some of them I've
never even heard of and after reviewing
some of the actual games you know these
guys are good right huh you know I'm
surprised that I've never heard of them
before and I'm enjoying going through
these games because they're not just
good but they were very exciting right
up until we started on the show actually
Robert was going through the games of
rounds four and five which were played
earlier today let's take a look at what
these players though are competing for
because it's not just all glory there is
some money on the line a $15,000 prize
fund the richest prize fund in a hat in
the history of quick chess on the
African continent with a top prize of
$5,000 now earlier today as we were
saying there were several cool games
that we need to look at several quirks
as well Robert what did you have in mind
from Round four so we still have a few
minutes before today's round starts so I
made a little bit of a selection here of
some of the games that happen today that
we could review now from Round four I
liked the game between Bassin amine
and one of Africa's talented junior
players you can pronounce them by reko
tomorrow that's that's a strong yeah so
in this game well let's let's hold off
here for a second there we go we were
still on the prizes but yeah let's see
if we can get the board up because we're
gonna look at a game from Round four as
we see one of the leaders bossom amin
taking on five rocoto mahara with the
black pieces and I got a little sassy in
this game take us through it show us
what happened yeah so we'll go through
the opening fairly quickly because I
think both players played some normal
moves
decent position either side again we see
the trade of Bishop for Knight becoming
a sort of at an opening theme I mean a
lot of the games we've covered we've
talked about this idea and here it's
actually I approve of Bishop takes
because at least we're doubling some
pawns and that's the exception yeah I
mean whenever you trade to the bishop
for a knight you got to be getting
something for it can't just be
considered an equal trade you know like
they're both worth three so it's okay
that's not gonna cut it so we need to
get like some kind of structural damage
accomplished or win some material
something in this case we're getting
some doubled pawns but anyway after
white took on c6 expanded on the
queenside castle both sides completed
development but soon after development
was finished things started to get a
little bit complicated you don't
normally see the rook getting to the
seventh rank so quick in the game
usually we associate this with end games
so white is getting active on the Queen
side and now after d4 we see some of the
problems about having these doubled
pawns on c6 especially as these doubled
pawns on the C file especially this pawn
on c6 because now after C D 494 there's
a very nasty threat of Knight takes c6
not that easy to deal with the game
black brought the Queen out Queen d6
night a three and we see that the
Knights start harassing the Queen we've
heard of this concept I'm sure when
we're first starting out that we
shouldn't bring our Queen out too soon
because it can become vulnerable and
these two knights in the center are
gonna do a great job at harassing the
black queen so now after rook b7 white
traded and played Knight c4 and we see
that even though black has the bishop
pair they don't seem to be participating
so much yet
now this can change remember the bishops
are always ready to spring into action
but as long as we have these pawns on c6
and f6
have time so after Queen B 4 B 3 9 d 892
C 5 we see that black is being mindful
of his bishops bring it at least one of
them into the game and after Queen d7
Bishop takes e4 Bishop d2 we get a very
important moment in the game threatening
the Queen threatening the Queen I mean
whenever your queen is under attack you
should consider it a pretty important
moment in the game now normally we would
want to move our Queen away but that
doesn't seem so easy here because our
queen is trapped so do we lose our Queen
well no black throws in this in-between
move Bishop c6 which turns out to be a
terrible blunder
because after Queen a7 the Queen is
still trapped and black resigned now at
first I thought this is actually what
black had planned for because after
Queen b5
since the Queen is no longer on d7 or
Queens no longer trapped but the Knights
start chasing the Queen and after Queen
before Knight d5 we'd be 597 the Knights
have sort of crawled her way up the
board and trapped the black Queen I
think she's actually trapped now she is
yeah yeah yeah
so I think that's why black resigned but
it was a nice I guess case study on what
happens when you bring your queen out a
little bit too soon but just to defend
black a little bit because I think black
had played well could have tried Bishop
f5 here and this would have made a
difference because after Queen to a7 we
can go Queen b5 in 93 and our Bishop is
not in the way on c6 so the Queen can
actually retreat to D 7 or 8 and we
don't lose the Queen which is always
nice so
that's the big highlight I think from
Round four would you like to look at
again from around five absolutely I like
that he was hoping it's a important to
note that with that loss Rico tomorrow
gave up a plus-one very slight lead in
the field and now the grand master
doctor from Egypt Bassam Amin is one of
the leaders and so yeah we are now in
rapid round five but what game are you
looking at here Robert well I think
today might be the day of amine because
another amine gaming yeah he is catching
up I mean we saw him trailing the field
after day one but after this nice win
and after the win in round five he is
among the leaders so I wanted to show
you not a whole game but actually a
position on move 29
I mean sacrifices new exchange rook
takes d3 Queen takes t3 rook the 8th and
after Queen e2 Queen b6 and in in
exchange I guess before the exchange can
you say it that way well I'm going to
you get this tremendous pressure on the
D file you're gonna get the knight back
on d2 and after a couple of moves before
and white threw in the towel because
after the Queen moves even though we're
focusing on the D file all of a sudden
after b3 this night on 82 is completely
dominated and white loses even more
material so a couple of big wins by a
mean and he is on fire today so he's the
guy to watch it's important to note that
if you'd like to follow along the games
with us you can do so at chess 24 calm
this is the C IV rapid and blitz
Invitational join us chess 24 calm
African chess news calm want to give
them a big shout out yesterday they had
full coverage of the first day and just
the best way to read up on any rounds
you may have missed if you don't have
time to watch these great broadcasts
here from st. Louis so what else do we
have Robert we have about five minutes
until the start of round number six of
the rapids all right well games are not
lacking
we have plenty to choose from we have
content yes content yes so there was a
game by player we interviewed yesterday
Chi Yan day is that right
I owned a I owned a yes that I thought
was quite interesting around for ya
round round for so let me see if I can
it's a good round for Andrew yeah here
we go now this was a crazy game is this
round for ya right yes that's right so
in this game even though we had a
completely different opening the
position sort of reminded me of the Amin
game we looked at after just some pretty
normal opening play I mean both sides
simply developed castled and started
fighting for the center white played
this idea Queen d2 Bishop h6 no in the
Russell emos is a very normal plan as
well usually when you trade off one of
your bishops for a knight what you want
to do is you want to trade off the other
vision for one of your opponent's
bishops you know what this is going to
accomplish it's actually something very
important what happens when you give
your Bishop up for a knight what does
your opponent get come on well I mean if
it's not the game it would be a bit of
Bishop err
yeah the bishop pair and the bishop pair
is a huge strategic advantage so it
makes sense to try to trade off your
last bishop for one of your opponent's
bishop pair in this case we still have
our light square bishop so we're not
really afraid of our opponents bishop
pair but we are pretty interested in
taking control over the dark squares
because that is going to create some
serious King safety issues for black and
after d5e 594 Queen f4 I think even
though Kai owned a won this game he was
in a little bit of pressure here after
Bishop takes Queen takes f6 rook e1
f-five White's position is very very
good and very dangerous for black white
play Knight f5 and I think this might be
rushing things a little bit there is one
piece of whites that's not really
participating yet and I think maybe
Knight h4 would have been an improvement
because when we take on f5 we want to
make sure that after G takes f five we
can sort of reload and put another night
on f5 and threat and checkmate on g7 so
I was I was wondering maybe after Knight
of fate how to proceed and in this
position if we take on f5 takes Knight
takes black might be able to play a six
and make it just in time to defend g7
along the seventh rank with the Queen so
we can actually throw in this movie six
with the idea of following up with
Knight takes at five and after we take
everything will land the knight on that
five and have a very nasty threat of
Queen g7 checkmate so just to sort of
give you an example if route d6 Knight
takes on five takes takes and now you're
gonna be under a lot of pressure I mean
you're basically getting checkmated I
think maybe Knight takes c6 here and I
know maybe a rook lifts here with rook
e3 maybe take on e4 first so at this
point I'm just wondering how in the
world white lost yeah that is a good
question so he took on f5 right away and
after pawn takes Queen e6 check King h8
takes takes Knight g5 now usually the
Queen and Knight are the deadliest team
around together they can do all sorts of
neat tricks that for example Queen and
Bishop can't do as well so it's
generally considered the Queen and
Knight is better than Queen and Bishop
but after Knight f8 this night is gonna
play a very important defensive role for
texts h7
and it pretty much holds blacks position
together after night f7 King g7 takes
rook takes and it seems like White's
attack is fizzling out I mean Black has
two minor pieces for a rook if things
get a little bit out of control maybe
with rook III or g3 we always have the
option of playing Knight g6 but at the
moment we have to deal with the threat
on our queen like we did in the last
game blundering your queen it is never a
good thing
notice that here black can't take the
Queen because after Knight takes c6 we
have a nasty little fork so I think this
is where the game slowly starts to slip
away from White's control because after
rook takes Queen G for King h8 all of a
sudden this is the king doesn't look
like it's in too much trouble
f4 Queen b6 f5 CD 4 f6 and now after d3
black it's a very nice protected passed
pawn on d3 this should at least serve to
distract White's pieces from the attack
King h1 96 h4 rook g8 f7 rook f8 h5
Knight takes e5 and those white pawns
are dropping like flies
so Queen g5 26 Brooke a5 9 f 7 and
Knight f6 and now you're gonna lose the
pawn in f7 and look it this is kind of
strange to see right we don't usually
see four central pawns for one side yeah
so it looks like black has pretty good
control over the center with 4 central
pawns against none and these pawns start
rolling paint takes a triumph queen bee
497 rookie 5 Queen h3 King G one Queen
g3
oh and white resigned because if you
move King to h1 your rook is hanging and
if you defend your route your king is
hanging
right so a nice counter-attack by I
owned a alright excellent stuff yeah
well we we have just seen on chest 24
comm that the round is underway on the
Ivory Coast at the hotel Tiana so let's
take a look at some of the action that's
happening in round six let's go around
the horn and see what do we have all the
games yet yeah it looks like yeah
alright so here we have slim Volodya
against Kenny Solomon and it looks like
another aggressive game but I wouldn't
feel too bad about blacks position we're
talking about a similar position
yesterday where black usually goes rook
e8 and f8 tucks the Bishop away and
slowly completes his development with
modes like Bishop d7 Queen c7 of course
or Knight is hanging so we can't really
dwell on these vague ideas too much but
here maybe we can just go Knight takes D
3 Queen takes D 3 and now we're key 8
followed by a bishop f8 I don't think
black should have a lot of problems in
this position should we see what yeah
this position was still going yeah
alright so what do we have here
this isn't huh it's certainly not a draw
already they Deezy showing that it's a
draw this game over they're just getting
started
no it can't be it there cannot be a draw
at this point is there a like a 30 move
draw rule in this tournament yes uh yeah
actually there's I need to double-check
it may actually be different for the
blitz rounds oh it might be like a 20
move or 40 move or something I feel like
I read something different I'll check up
on that all right well this tournament
is exactly the same format as the rapid
and blitz tournaments in the grand
chests or I don't know
oh that is the inspiration behind this
behind this event yeah so in either case
whether this has ended in the draw which
we don't think it has the game is just
getting started it's really hard to to
make an assessment here I mean both
sides are just gonna play normal moves
I'm guessing
what happened here oh maybe this was a
draw because it was like a repetition
yeah Wow yeah threefold
why would you do something like this at
this at this juncture I don't know
you mean you play a rapid or a blitz
tournament you know it's a all or
nothing so maybe this wasn't wrong
because a threefold repetition is
usually considered an exception right
yeah so this is okay this is a draw that
and this this game moving on that Arthur
seg Hwanhee and David Silva they're both
middle of the row Graham how so all
right so let's see what we have here oh
this is my guy there is amin Bassam I'm
getting excited about his games I mean I
didn't know I had seen some games of his
throughout the years I think roughly my
age so I might have my age too we're the
same age oh my god and we're both
wearing lapel pins look at that pin yeah
Oh where's these pivots on your right
yeah I forgot my grand chessboard yes we
have so much in common
crazies great yeah yeah so look at the
eyes of the Cerebral Assassin of chess
right there I'm talking about bossom
Amin there that's intimidating I mean
he's got that have you ever heard of the
tall stair yes absolutely yeah he's got
a little bit of that going on yes scary
anyway Amin is from what I understand a
bit of a specialist and expert in the
Kings Indian attack and that's what we
got in this game normally in the Kings
in the attack White is hoping that black
will castle really early which is
something you generally shouldn't do
because if you do it too soon then your
opponent knows exactly where he should
attack you whereas if you keep the king
in the center a little bit you keep him
guessing you know where's the king gonna
go Kings like Queen side maybe in the
center so that's what black is doing
here clear out the entire back rank and
I never know which one exactly so
usually in the Kings Indian attack white
wants to put this pawn on e5 and that's
gonna be sort of the wedge that is gonna
drive the attack because it's gonna take
away the key f6 square we usually want
to put a knight to defend your king side
but here since black didn't castle
what's kind of waiting he's gonna make
some moves like a 3 B 4 9 f 1 hoping
that soon
black will Castle and play d5 so this
game is really gonna depend on where
black puts this king but it's really
early in the game still so hard to tell
moving on
absolutely all right remember these
games are gaming 25 with a 10 second
delay so while we're still early on it
won't be like that for long yes sir
so now we have hadoo che Mohammed it's
all right I've been saying Mohammed
hadoo sh but it's tough to tell at this
point well it sounds like a you know a
French inspired name and I always see
that little like accent on the e like
hide your shame oh is that is that on
the end of his name
I don't know I might seen that yet I'm
gonna I'm gonna make it up and say that
it is because it sounds really
sophisticated so how do shame against
old Adamu adieu the Nigerian player yep
so let's see what we have in this game
so black has the bishop pair and he has
more central pawns so normally this
would make me very happy but white does
have it lead in development and this
really weird-looking knight on age 5 I
mean how did that and I get there so
black is gonna have to complete this
development somehow and get this Knight
into the game but I don't know I'm
liking White's position here I don't
think it's gonna be easy to do both
things at the same time let's say this
game I think went h6 Bishop e3 so how is
black we're gonna fix these problems is
he is he trying to go g5 and then bring
the Knight to g7 and e 6 that seems very
optimistic I'd be a little bit scared
maybe he's just trying to get the bishop
out of g5 so that you can go Bishop e7
Castle and if this Knight gets in
trouble just dropped back to f6 that
makes a lot more sense I don't know why
I even consider g5
yeah so maybe this is okay for blind
because if you go Bishop H for the night
of four is coming and this night looks
very active on that floor so we have to
go Bishop III Bishop e7 now if I'm right
here I know time is not on my side
because if I allow black to go Castle
kingside Knight f6 he's just gonna have
the bishop pair more central pawns but
maybe that open B file is going to give
him some counter play so I got to do
something fast
I'm thinking maybe c5 so this is going
to break up black's pawn structure I'm
also going to be trading a non central
pawn for a central pawn so strategically
speaking there is some logic behind this
and after D takes c5 I think I have
pretty good chances of getting this pawn
back for example with Knight a four rook
c1 and eventually Bishop takes c5 now a
little while ago
we were talking about this concept that
when you trade one of your bishops for a
knight and you leave your opponent with
the bishop pair you usually want to
trade off this bishop that you have left
for one of your opponent's bishops so
this idea of c5 is gonna help me carry
out that strategic goal for example if
black goes castles I can go Bishop takes
c5 let's say black throws in this move
Knight a4 queen III takes nine takes I'm
pretty happy that's white I took away
your Bishop pair I ruined your pawn
structure
I created this week isolated pawn on c6
which I can very easily exploit with
rook a c1 and overall this just looks
like a good position for white so I
think the game so far has progressed
until Bishop e3
I suppose black is gonna go Bishop e7
and if white doesn't play the c5 move
very soon you can find himself in
trouble so
so that was the fourth game right yeah
there's one more UND let's do it alright
what do we have here Andrew Chi and a
sort of the the Cinderella story of the
tournament the six-time Zambian national
that's right yesterday you said four
times yeah you'll check your sheet I
changed it it changes it six nine four
yes okay but what do you would it be
fair to say he's the like the Cinderella
story of the tournament I mean this is
who I had in mind when I was telling you
like there's a lot of players that I've
never heard of before that when you look
through their games you know they're
tough I mean he almost won a game
against us enemy Nestor day right and I
mean he and he's trailing the leader of
the tournament it just in terms of what
rating strength about 300 points yeah
with all of that factor and I think
absolutely Cinderella story yeah be a
good assessment so what do we have here
I mean first thing that stands out is
Bishop hair right so what does black
have to offset it let's see the pawns
both sides have what seven pause no
Black has eight pawns so black is up at
pawn is that right am i counting right I
am yeah I'm getting confirmation that I
am counting right so black has an extra
pawn this should make up for the bishop
pair because if you ever try to get this
pawn back wait what oh wait and I'm
literally counting pawns right one two
three four five six seven okay I'm
getting confirmation that I do have
problems counting so it is seven I guess
it's like one time that I'm proving to
myself I'm not going crazy yes yeah
you're right I am so what's the
trade-off I do have a vision for what as
a math professor so this is gonna change
things a little bit because this pawn on
c4 looks kind of weak let me get rid of
these annoying highlights I made
so we're gonna run the risk of losing
this pawn and we're also gonna run the
risk of getting crushed on dark squares
because we see this fianchettoed King
but there's something missing a bishop
yeah the fianchettoed Bishop so if I was
white I wouldn't get distracted with the
c-4 pawn I would maybe try to capture it
later on in the game if the opportunity
arises but I'm much more tempted to go
for this King so maybe with a move like
Queen d2 h4 and h5 and try to start
jabbing at this fianchetto maybe it was
moves like Bishop h6 and h4 h5 Queen f4
I can start bothering you a little bit
maybe I used to think when I was
teaching beginners how to play that
whenever you push the Jeep on and you're
gonna Castle if you if you're not gonna
fill it with a bishop it's kind of like
you've created a tree that's rotting
from the center I never heard that
aggressively weak and it would be
otherwise yeah absolutely I mean the
fianchetto is a double-edged sword I
mean it's very nice as long as you have
that bishop there because as we said
earlier you know bishops you want them
pointing at the center but you don't
want them physically in the center
because they can get attacked quite
easily
now here this would be an exception on
d5 this bishops actually doing very well
in the center because there's just no
way to attack it right this pawn on c4
makes it so that white can't play see
for himself and moves like Bishop f3
would actually help us achieve a piece
trade that we are willing to embrace
right we want to get rid of white's
bishop pair so if white plays a move
like Bishop f3 here well it's actually
blacks move so let's say I go knight c6
if you try to get rid of my bishop on d5
with Bishop f3 I'm gonna be pretty happy
because then my Queens gonna go to d5
maybe I can go something like f6
and now actually I have some pretty good
control over the light squares overall I
think Andrew Cayenne days position is
considerably better because of course
he's not forced to make this terrible
trade instead against knight c6 why not
h4 Alessi fives possible no no not a big
deal
so yeah I would go h4 h5 maybe throwing
Queen d2 so I'm not so sure about the
move order yet but these are the the two
big factors in my plan not midnight yet
for Cinderella huh it's not midnight yet
for Cinderella no not at all not even
close hey we've got to go to Bassam
amines game with mocha Sela Nani okay it
looks like possums in trouble really
just from a quick glance all right let
me pull that game up and they're on the
move fifteen so what happened here last
time we saw this game I think we were at
Queen e2 and at this point black played
Bishop a6 which makes sense putting some
pressure on d3 right 'if I've also
consistent with White's idea hoping that
black will Castle kingside it this is
called castling into the attack
it's not something you generally want to
do that's it you can tell from the name
yeah yeah h6 and this is very
interesting because we can appreciate
the advantage of having left the King in
the center now black is preparing to
play g5 and after that go Knight g6 so
the pawn that's usually an asset for
white it's gonna become a liability
because if we've castles King side going
h6 g5 looks very risky it would just
weaken our King
but since our King is in the center we
can pretty much go crazy on the King
side and then what our King on the other
side of the board
so if black is able to get g5 96 it's
gonna be almost impossible for white to
defend the pawn
five because like it's also gonna be
threatening to push his pawn to g4
and who's gonna defend any five it's not
gonna be easy and it's not like we can
play d4 because this guy on a6 is
keeping an eye on her Queen it looks
like a chain reaction of bad yeah yeah
so usually you want to wait till your
opponent castles King side to go E 5 so
after H 4 so this is stopping G 5 or is
it boom
g 5 anyway H takes g 5h takes Knight
takes and now we take on e5 so we didn't
win the pawn on e5
that we did make a good pawn trade
because what ended up happening we
traded our jeep on which is not a
central point for the e5 pawn which is
not only that if white were to trade
Queens here things would spiral out of
control because after Knight takes now
this pawn on d3 is very weak then if d4
93 and now the pawn on d4 is weak so
this is sort of a chain reaction like
you were saying but I mean had something
in mind and played Knight d2 e for what
like crazy move right just putting your
knight in the path of attack yeah so
what happens if black takes this pawn I
mean what is his idea I guess he wants
to go Bishop f4 and if you play Queen d5
oh look at this D takes e4 threatening
the Queen and the bishop so you
basically have to take my queen and now
I take your queen and your knight on c6
is under attack and your Bishop on e2 is
under attack
oh very nice so it's a very nice tactic
yeah I don't know though I don't I mean
of course Queen d5 would really be
cooperating with your opponent maybe
Black has a better move I don't think he
takes d3 works because I mean can I just
take on e5 or can do something like
Bishop takes I think you go D takes e -
Bishop takes g7 rook e8
No so if I take here you take takes
procreate
and it would seem like you're gonna take
one of these pieces but after Bishop f6
I couldn't protect everything and at
least I'm not losing any more material
but nevertheless this looks kind of
interesting for black because this pawn
on e2 looks very strong well the white
does have the bishop pair but I don't
know this looks a little bit suspicious
to me no is there something better for
white after he takes d3 I'm wondering
what a what black has in mind after
Knight d4 maybe didn't see Knight d4 I
know I probably wouldn't oh look at this
after Bishop takes c6 check Knight takes
c6 I can create a discovery on your
Queen oh and then also threaten your
knight and there's no good way for you
to retreat the Queen n defend the knight
right because you can't go Queen D 5
because that pawn on e6 is pinned so
everything I told you about keeping the
King in the center you may want to
forget that at least in this position so
it's a little too late you got to know
when to do it when to know well and also
you know chess is a struggle so you can
have your own strategy and it's a
legitimate strategy and your opponent is
gonna try to make life hard for you
right and I think that's what Amin is
trying to do by playing this Knight d4
most sort of highlight the fact that you
haven't Castle so it's an extreme
measure trying to take advantage of the
most important chess team in the whole
game I'm just king safety so yeah do we
have any more moves from this game I
don't think so right I think so the last
move I have
yes it's 94 right so maybe black isn't
forced to take the night I mean you
probably have to take tonight though
because otherwise Bishop f4 is coming so
after Bishop f4 he takes d3 maybe that's
the blunder right maybe we should just
retreat the Queen because queen takes d5
is bad he takes d3 is bad let's just get
the Queen out of here but maybe he's
just gonna go Knight takes e4 and now
after the Queen moves again is there 96
absolutely 96 yeah and this is gonna be
one of those intuitive peace sacrifices
because I don't necessarily see a force
to win for white but we do have a king
that's stranded in the center because we
can't go to c7 because that would just
expose our King to some discoveries but
also this Knight doesn't look that
stable on d6 usually when you thrust
your knight into the opponent's side of
the board you got to be sure what you're
doing normally you want that night on an
outpost as some kind of guarantee that
it'll be stable there otherwise you can
find it very soon it's going to become a
target because talking about chain
reactions this Knight is protected by
this bishop so if something happens to
this Bishop then this Knight is going to
suffer the consequences all right so
what's your assessment of the game after
fourteen and a half moves have been
played 14 and a half so White's made the
15th right but
all right so night after night need for
you mean yes no I
oh pardon me more moves really yeah
ok yes so we have d tasty for you know
Bishop f4 okay
Queen d5 Queen d5 now I thought they'd
reconsider this a blunder we're we
talking about this way maybe
ya know I think we didn't look at this
exact move order we were looking at
Reedy so Bishop f4 we were just looking
at
IDI and Queen f6 so Queen d5 does make
some sense because if white tries to
open up the diagonals for the bishop we
can just retreat back to d7 and the
Queen's gonna help out protecting the
knight on c6 and again we have our
knight sort of wandering about our
opponent's camp and even though it's not
under attack yet it's not particularly
stable either what's going on in this
position I think that taking into
account that after Bishop takes e4 Queen
d7 there's no direct threat maybe the
move this Knight takes e4 but then it's
d3 hanging the reason I like Knight
takes e4 is because I'm threatening a
discovery here with 96 so if you move
your queen away with Queen d7 again I
can try to throw in this check but now
you can go to the other side right King
f8 so this is the nice thing about
having a king of the center you can sort
of dodge those punches as they start
coming in but I would assess this
position as white being on the edge of
the cliff you know it looks like he
might be able to deliver a knockout blow
but my impression is that black has
plenty of defensive resources to hold it
together
and yeah this is where the game is that
right now after Queen d5 what about the
other games let's see what what's
happening here hi Dru Shay as we've
established his name is I guess I'll go
along with that
yeah all right so the last time we
looked at this game we had seen Bishop
e3 with the idea of going c5 so instead
of Bishop e7 black played Bishop d6
and white went rook AC one I think it's
definitely a step in the same direction
that we were taking but now after rook
the 8th maybe it's gonna be a little bit
harder to play c5 because we've got
these x-rays on our queen
maybe c5 should have been considered
right away
just giving up the pawn but let's see
what happened rook c1 rook d8 h3 Queen B
a and C fine all right so pretty much
the same idea but the difference is that
now by including the moves work the ADA
and Bishop e6 black doesn't take on this
shattered pawn structure with DC 5 the
plays in the center Queen B 5 takes
takes Trading Queens looks kind of
dangerous because in an endgame when
your opponent has two central pawns you
don't have any and he has the bishop
pair and you don't trading Queens is
only going to highlight those factors
now here maybe things aren't so easy
because this night on h5 is not
participating and perhaps white is gonna
have enough time to snatch up that
bishop pair with 97 96 because we're
also threatening to take on 87 so this
is called compensating a strategic
weakness with you know some concrete
variations so you can't just say oh I
have the bishop pair and better and then
get made it into moves that doesn't work
like that
so after d4 Bishop d2
this is where the game is at right now
and this is kind of unpleasant because
even though we have a nice position we
have a pawn hanging on a7 the pawn
hanging on e5 the misplaced night on h5
so optically blacks position was very
good I mean we had a lot of things of
abstract value like bishop pair center
but we can't really hold down that
position that being said I mean if I had
to give up one pawn it much rather give
up a seven then e fine but maybe I can
get away with this move a six maybe not
because I was hoping that if you go
Knight c7 King disseminate ake my bishop
all of a sudden I've managed not to lose
upon and to activate my King in the
endgame so actually this King on d5 for
example it would be quite nice besides
you know a 6 e 4 worth considering so e
for and what's gonna happen after Knight
takes pawn because you don't have enough
time to play a 6 I think I can go either
97 check
well if Knight takes c6 f takes c6 these
guys are gonna be hanging but I think I
can just do check and after King d7 for
example Knight takes pawn takes I've
kind of made your pawns ugly and I can
just consolidate my position moves like
Bishop III rook FD 1 this is starting to
look close to winning for white yeah so
I don't know this blacks position is not
so convincing anymore it's been a tough
tournament so far for I do he's sitting
at one point for a possible ten okay
grandmaster from Algeria Muhammad had
Boucher no no it's a douche a baby so
you're like improving on my version I
like that we're adding different
elements here okay there's no way to
tell right now slight yeah he may be on
the road to another two pointer let's
check up on our friend Andrew Chi Yan
day what a good friend he is yeah I like
the the interview with him he was really
upbeat great guy yeah so where did we
leave off on this game
Bishop d5 castles yeah so we had this
position and I was talking about the
move knight c6 and oh actually it wasn't
castles I was talking about the move h4
h5 trying is that right where was she -
hanging the whole time or maybe I had
castles and I was playing aged for
anyway
I would do that yeah that's right
so after Queen d7 rook me one Queen c6
this is an interesting idea by black
because he really wants us well he would
love us to play a move like Bishop takes
f3 and after Bishop takes Queen takes
Queen takes pawn takes because now as
black we don't really have to worry
about our weak dark squares usually
don't get mated in the endgame at least
not so easily and we've managed to
shatter White's King side so even if we
lose the point of the b-pawn I think we
can get a lot of compensation for
example was it move like B 6 if takes
takes maybe rook takes
can I do something like Knight d7 and if
Brooke b7 I wanted to do Knight f6 so
that if you take here I have a knight d5
what do you think of this position when
you look at it this is my way of priming
you to count the pause because I'm not
feeling confident yeah notability five
six four why okay you know I mean as as
an elementary thinker I would say that
the the Jeep on for why it looks a
little misplaced but I would still
strongly prefer white really so I think
there's my off base here Robert I've
been this is almost winning for black oh
my god yeah so close but not close I'm
not that close so I am down to pawns but
where are those two pawns I mean this is
one and it looks terrible I mean this
work is gonna take it sooner rather than
later
this Knight is creating some very
concrete threats I mean it's like a
triple fork right on the rook the bishop
and the pawn on c3 and we have a live C
pawn I mean as soon as we take on c3
that guy's going to start rolling so in
order to avoid losing material you would
have to do something like rook efore and
then I could already start chopping down
some pawns the knight takes c3 or maybe
rook takes a two just to keep my knight
centralized this would be I think a
nightmare for white so that's just one
illustrative variation of what I would
be looking for in this position is black
but let's see what happened in the game
rookie 197 bishop f1 so not trading
these bishops that's usually a good idea
and look at this tucking the bishop away
for later very nice h4 better late than
never
b6 takes takes rook b2
Brook a3 and rook be2 this is where
we're at in the game honestly I think
Black has improved his position
tremendously from the last time we
discussed it because first of all he
completed all his development he opened
up the a file exposing the weakness
going too far with the arrow or too
short anyway this bond I need to is weak
and h4 happened but it happened kind of
late and I don't think this is going to
amount to much of an attack after h5 so
I think Black has some concrete threats
here and white is gonna have to play
very accurately to keep the balance so I
think this game is trending in blacks
favor but as we saw in the previous
round we saw a game were-coyote played
this great counter attacking game so
definitely black shouldn't be counting
his chickens yet another game I think we
should switch to is the grandmaster game
of the day or of the round
Valhalla vs. Solomon Oh Kenny's in good
shape right now really yes
so Kenny has the black pieces and
[Music]
engines are saying - five - five okay so
let's we have quite a few moves from the
last time we saw this game which was
after f4 so I had said after Knight
takes D three Queen takes me through
your key a black seemed to be doing okay
but in the game we saw this Queen check
first and after king h1 then Knight
takes D three and ninety four so very
aggressive I think this is a style of
the tournament and you know even though
we have 10 players from 10 different
countries they all like to play quite
aggressively so that's one for us it's
fun for us also enemy it's a window and
there's something in
to a group of people we don't usually
get to see yeah absolutely so 94
threatening a very nasty little pork
here on f2 Queen f3 and f5
he takes f5 Bishop takes h3 Knight f6 g4
so this is one of the dangers when you
advanced your minor piece is too far
into your opponent's camp you run the
risk of getting chased away so we're
like we see now with h3 g4
however I think in this case it is not
without danger for white because the
pawns you're moving forward are the
pawns that are also protecting your king
so Bishop e6 b3 rook e8 now I I'm quite
excited by the prospect putting my
bishops on da and d7 getting out of the
way of the rooks because if these two
rooks are allowed to operate freely
along the enf files
I think White's position might become
very dangerous so Bishop e3 Queen a 5f5
Bishop f7c I would have jumped at the
chance of playing Bishop c8 and saving
this Bishop for later but maybe Black
has something else in mind to go d5
something along those lines
97 Knight g3c fine bishop g 195 queen e3
Bishop g5 Wow
so the idea is that well this is what
happened Queen takes Queen takes c3 f6
Bishop g6
Bishop h2 rook takes f6 so was Bishop h2
a blunder here maybe because after rook
takes f6 the rook on a1 is hanging so
maybe white needed to prepare this
Bishop h2 move I don't know with a move
like can we go something like oh no but
wait a minute
this Knight is hanging on g3 no wonder
huh maybe this isn't so easy anymore
look at this white chased away the black
minor pieces and expose this King and
now we can't move the rook away from a1
because the knight is hanging we can't
move the knight because H 3 is also
hanging so we have to defend this knight
on c3 but after Bishop h2 rook takes f6
if we take here I think we're gonna run
into a nasty in between Queen takes a 1
check instead of Bishop H instead of
Bishop h2 is why just forced to maybe
try to trade off Queens like cleaning
III yeah this is a good idea Magnus
Carlsen calls that pulling the emergency
brake
so after let's get out of here
yeah Queen takes bishop takes I'm
wondering if there's not a discovery to
target this bishop for example something
like Knight takes e4 and after B takes
c4 rook takes c3 you traded Queens but
you're not out of the woods yet
I mean I'm threatening to take your
knight again you can't move the night
because the pawn is hanging I'm gonna
take on f6 and the position opens up and
when the position opens up the bishop
should be better than this night on g3
and it's Knight just is having a hard
time whether it's a middle game or an
end game now officially we can say that
Kenny Sullivan has clinched two points
from this game oh wow so there he won
Wow excellent alright so let's see the
other games
muhammad had Bouchet is what about
looking good
let me go to the Amin game because I see
we have some moves here oh yes and that
was a crazy game so after Queen D 5 D
takes e4 we had looked at this and we
saw that Bishop takes e - he takes d5
and later D takes c6 but now Queen takes
Queen takes a 6 Wow what is this Queen
h5 so black is up a piece Queen b7
rooks yeah like is up a piece but this
clean side seems to be under siege right
this this Queen snuck into b7 and I'm
worried that maybe black is gonna have
his Knights tied down if I'm able to get
like Bishop d6 + e5 in I don't know
maybe that takes too long so why play d5
right away now are we threatening
anything in this position oh my eyes are
looking to the bishop on g2 yeah but if
Bishop takes c6 of course we wouldn't go
Knight takes c6 because then the rook
would be hanging but after Bishop c6 we
just go rook takes c6 and we're
threatening Queen h1 checkmate so we
can't just give up this Bishop unless
it's for something really really good
but look at this no black just castles
move 20 and black castles now I I'm I
would be very proud of a situation like
this you know I black held out on
castling until it was absolutely
necessary we shouldn't forget the
castling as a passive defensive move so
we should only do it if it's necessary
otherwise there's tons of other
productive things that you can come up
with and here I'm just sensing that very
soon Weiss is gonna be down at peace
because this King is looking awfully
safe on g8 now rook a d1 so trying to go
for rook d7
rook b8 Queen a6 so kicking the Queen
out of that annoying b7 square and now
Knight takes e5 this position seems to
be almost collapsing for white if black
is able to go Knight f3 we're gonna have
to give up our G to Bishop and there
goes all our compensation although it
may be still the rook on b8 a thing so
we shouldn't jump to conclusions yet but
I think I don't know it's black morning
here I can always just play Knight 7 to
g6 right because if work b79 of 3
doesn't make much sense because after
Bishop takes Queen takes I can just take
on e7 but I can just go Knight g6
getting my night out of the attack
attacking your Bishop on f4 and if you
give up the bishop pair well now I'm
just really happy right because that was
the essence of your compensation after
rook takes a 7 I can probably play
something like Knight f3 forcing you to
weaken the position of your King by
giving up this can Kaito bishop or maybe
I don't even need to rush I can just
play rook FD 8 bring my work to the open
D fun somehow I'm just tend to tempt it
to take this bishop away from you yeah
this is not looking good for Amin let's
see the other games we have the you were
mentioning that the odd you Shea is that
Howard a douche a and I do yeah I do
Shea's looking really good right now
okay so aneesa's where did we leave this
game off oh this was that raw Selim oh
okay so we were looking at the position
after Bishop d2 where all of blacks
pawns are hanging out all of them just
two of them but they're important yeah
but they're even if it was just one it
would still be important so rook c8
Knight takes e5
and Bishop takes c5 b4 so okay black
figured he five is a lost cause
I'll just trade it off for c5 try to get
my king out of the center but I should
not that worried about the king and more
worried about this night not
participating so if I had another move
oh just go nine of six but
understandably if we cancel we connect
the rooks and since we're fighting for
an open file connecting the rooks is
going to be pretty important so I would
be castling not because of my king but
rather because I want to connect the
rooks so don't say like it you know
tonight when you're talking to the guys
be like you know you just wanted to put
his King in a safe place in Council
that's actually I could also go King e7
maybe and achieve the same goal while
keeping the king close to the center
because in any games that's usually a
good idea so b4 Bishop e7 9700 have to
give up the exchange was there no choice
like Bishop c4 cuz if I go Bishop b6
then you go Knight d6 and you fork me
there it's like if I move the bishop I
lose the exchange that's basically what
it comes down to but maybe can I do this
that way if you go be c5 I go a b5 and I
kind of keep things under control maybe
not very much but I don't know actually
this doesn't look so bad for black I
must be missing something here why can't
the King the black King just move
instead of giving up the exchange so
after Bishop e7 here well if you go to
f8 that's not going to work out very
well because after Knight takes c6 f
takes ecigs rook takes c8 it's a miracle
it's not checkmate but you'll have to go
bishop d8 and lose a ton of material
here the other option would be to go to
d8 but I think there you're going to
have problems on the opposite side
of the board because now I can fork you
here so I'm just gonna drive you insane
with these Knights you know Forks here
force their works everywhere it's just a
room full of forks yeah no one wants
that nope
so I'm guessing blacks only move here it
might have been a six the game went
Bishop e7 I guess black figured I'll
just cut my losses give up the exchange
maybe he thought up there Bishop d6 you
know he's gonna get some of this
material back but after rook takes a
seven if you take on e5 I check you and
I take your rook and then I have to
protected fast pause on the Queen side
this would be an easy win so castles
knight c6 d3 Bishop e3 Knight f6 this
position indeed does look busted for
black 95 Bishop e5 rook d7 rook b8 Oh
and usually if you have to trade rooks
you're gonna be out of counter play so
alright let's see how this game went
takes on d3 white is up what an exchange
and a pawn yeah this is game over
check Bishop c5 I should be fine Nate b7
Bishop d7 so this is where the game is
that I think this is a lost position for
black hopeless probably material
imbalance it's just too great and I
don't think the bishop pair is going to
be enough to compensate it especially
because it's not just an exchange oh
it's this pawn that has great potential
to Queen all right do we have any other
games that well I got a say in if hi
douche big fat douche a wins this we
should interview it oh cool that's
exciting I asked him how to say his name
are you gonna let me ask him some
questions
oh absolutely all right well you do want
to ask questions yesterday I did I
didn't ask questions okay
yeah they want to ask more I don't know
but maybe I thought like you didn't like
my questions and you were gonna let me
ask questions today yes whatever
questions you want really this is this
is a this is a wide open international
broadcast we're all having a good time
all right I got some questions okay so
is the Cuyuna game over doesn't appear
to be no but we have a lot of new moves
so let's see after rook B to e to black
went six Queens c1 rook a8 I like this
ganging up on this week isolated pawn on
8 to h5 white figures okay that a 2
point is a lost cause I gotta compensate
it with some kind of attack takes takes
take everything and now how is this
Queen gonna get involved
Bishop h2 I like this move so the Queen
maybe it's coming to g5 or age six and
maybe coupled with the rook swing like
rook III or h3 could give us some attack
yeah there we go
let's get the images of the players on
the screen if you don't mind yeah sure
there we go
all right so what do we have here
Black has maintained his extra pawn
White has activated his rook so black
will need to remain vigilant here so
he's gonna have to keep this Queen close
to the King site that way white doesn't
play something like Queen c1 queen h6
and checkmate us it's not clear how way
is gonna break through here but maybe
white could simply try to play along to
dark squares with a move like Queen
before I'm not really threatening to
take the pawn on c4 yet because I have
some back rank problems right if I go
Bishop takes c4 Bishop takes Queen takes
work a one I'm gonna have to give up my
Queen to avoid checkmate so maybe I can
just go Queen before and prepare bishop
takes c4 with something like Bishop f4
or Bishop g3
but I don't know here you might be able
to activate your rook or the work 81
okay one looks pretty included
yeah yeah so maybe we should start with
something like this like Bishop f4 and
try to get the King out of the back rank
so that when I go Queen before and you
go Queen a1 a true k1 I can go Bishop
takes c4 so this could be an interesting
idea I think that White's position is
not so bad I think the bishop pair
especially this dark square bishop
should be enough to make up for that
missing pawn all right so what other
games do we have here since the immune
games seems to have evolved quite a bit
let's see
we're worried Knight takes e5 okay so
white took Bishop takes Queen takes a
seven Bishop f6 so black still up a
piece for a pawn Knight g6 oh wait a
minute this doesn't look so clear
anymore did black just blunder this on
and f7 that's kind of an important pawn
too because if you go rook takes which
is what happened in the game I take on
b8 and these black pawns are really
going down I mean I'm gonna take
probably six I'm gonna take b6 and
generally I like you know the piece
instead of the pawns but if you give me
enough pawns you might convince me and
that the piece isn't worth it so rook
takes 95 and now
Queen d6 rook d7 Oh was this a blunder
because I was liking White's position it
seemed like black had some King safety
issues to boot but now after Queen b6
we're gonna have to deal with rook d1
check and that doesn't look like a fun
move to have to deal with I mean he
could white survive that I mean what
would you play because your queen is
kind of trapped too
I mean let's say you go Queen takes b6
then I go rook d1 and after Bishop to f1
I mean Knight f3 would be the first move
I look at and but after King G - if I go
Queen h2 check you go King f3 and you
start running away with your king I
don't really see any devastating checks
so can I just threaten your Bishop oh my
goodness
so maybe you can go Queen check and now
I mean after King up you have to drop
back with Queen g2 but here at the very
least I have a nasty discovery right
well nasty discovery or nasty checkmate
I was gonna take the rook on e6 then I
realize oh I can just do mating two
takes and checkmate right so I'm
thinking that white is just completely
lost now well and we have a we have more
moves on the board and this looks like
yeah it's it's similar to what we've
seen yeah ouch look at this Queen for a
rook that's not a good deal so after
rook d7 took on f6 took on d6 we need to
check
and this looks like a matter of time
right
I mean if King h2 I'm just gonna go
Knight g4 alright and I'm gonna take
this pawn and if you go Bishop f1 if
Knight g4 maybe you can play rook f5 but
if Knight f3 King G - hmm 9f three King
G - this looks like an annoying pattern
to have to deal with right look at this
hitting your rook threatening all sorts
of discoveries on your King this is a
reasonable position I think this game is
over I don't think that Fossum is gonna
be able to survive this no I don't think
so either
so now normally I would say let's take
let's talk to the winner of this game
vocalist Ellen Ani it does not speak
very good English
what does he speak French yes we I mean
we could talk to him through a
translator but we couldn't really do any
real analysis or anything it'd just be
generals we could talk to him and I
could give you my interpretation of what
he's saying no no they have an
interpreter over there oh really I'm not
bringing you into this oh man
all right but well yeah we're at we're
communicating with the folks over on
ivory coast is he and who would be good
to talk to later on big big win for mo
CLIs absolutely and that's why I kind of
want to have them on mm-hmm
so what other games are still going on
let's check in on Andrew K on day oh
this game was eventually drawn so after
rook a six no where is it over k a5
Bishop c7 rook a 7 Bishop d6 Queen f6 me
c1 so yeah it looks like black is just
too tied down to the Kings side and to
his Queen side pawns to really make
anything of his extra pawn so they just
repeated moves here
and the game was drawn alright and what
else do we have was only one game left
how do Sh a game yes over dude she has
one okay we knew that was going to
happen so with one game left
it's bossom amin vs Moakley cell add 19
this is the only game left the only one
okay so what happened here after Queen
e2 Ruth d5 Queen check Bishop f1 Knight
of three oh he went 90 to 92 I was
looking at Queenie 4 here but ok 92
check King f8 Bishop c4 this should be 5
sorry c4 King h3 Queenie 6 g 4 h6 King
g2 Queen g5 so whoa these moves are just
flying in so after Queen well they have
to be the players have less than 20
seconds yeah so the dgt board sometimes
they can't keep up
rent the player so Brooke d4 Bishop's
gone rook takes wait a minute
could this be a fortress for white I
mean I don't I don't think I can win
this anymore
trading that night for that bishop
wasn't a good idea
you're right and well at least hold on I
a guy can't get ahead of myself
it says draw right now but they agreed
to draw wow what a saved by a mean I
mean I thought his position was
reasonable a couple months ago it's wow
yeah well should we talk to a mean
perhaps how do you yeah I think I think
we should yeah I mean this is as good a
moment as any yeah yeah I mean I'm sure
he's feeling pretty happy now that thing
to mention about fortresses is that
chess engines are almost always fooled
by them now they're looking at material
and they're looking at other things but
the fortress is just the king can run
and you just can't trap them you can't
put them away yeah and also just from a
conceptual point of view when you have
little time this is the best time
to rely on general principles because
you don't have time to think so you have
to make the move that looks good and
previously we were talking about how
Queen and Knight are usually better than
Queen and Bishop so you can only imagine
how Queen and Knight are better than
rook and Bishop so we should try to keep
Queen and Knight
usually this is a very powerful
attacking combo so I think that a black
simply straight here thinking that okay
I have an extra Queen the pea strains
should help me but in fact peace trays
can be your biggest enemy sometimes you
know you get blinded by the fact that
okay I trade pieces I trade pieces I'm
up a queen and that's how fortress has
happened so instead of Queen e6 pretty
much any move I even think that a move
like ninety four would have probably
been winning I have a little trick in
mind that if you go Bishop takes e4
Queen h1 King g4 I can fork you and we
start seeing how important it was to
keep the knight on the board alright so
I guess all the games are over all the
games are over yeah did we their friends
did we miss any game that we didn't
cover yeah we glanced at the finish of
hadoo Shay yeah but we figured that
would be a way for him so yeah that's
true I mean I don't think it makes that
much sense to well why not you never
know what happens let me just run
through this really quick so after king
h7 this is where he had left off so the
game didn't go too much longer
ninety-eight they shook the age Bishop
you sound look at this cluster of pieces
what's going on here there should be
five night cakes
okay so blacks position just collapsed
no surprises there okay yeah it's pretty
much what we were expecting are you
gonna get for our interview have you
decided yet well it I have decided it
looks like we are going to get possum
Amin on the line first oh we're still
working on that the way that we're
working with this by the way I'm calling
by a Skype the international arbiter
Stefan asked opera I think that's how
you say his name you know I played in a
World Junior Championship a long time
ago it's like over ten years ago it was
held in Yerevan Armenia and his fellow
countrymen oddly Achmed was playing and
in the first round in the first round we
both got upset we lost our games and I
figured okay I'm in good company but
then he won the tournament and I still
kept losing so I think that's the first
time I realized how good this guy was
all right we got you're seeing it all
here folks what are you doing
we are clipping on a microphone so we
can hear our friends over here and I all
right I got the volume up turn my camera
off
yes there this alright we have the top
seed in the tournament
Grand Master dr. bossom Amin you
you've got out of this one just by the
skin of your teeth possum first of all
welcome to the show you got into this
amazing fortress ending what were your
thoughts as you finished this game well
I'm relieved of course it was totally
lost position and I just kept fighting
okay I think my sacrifice in the opening
was ok interesting but maybe enough
compensation of the road and ok once it
doesn't and he took my phone if I if it
persists over then ok he missed this
root of seven three peso time back in
the game but again after taking from f7
taken be a few g7 I think the position
still very difficult because they 95 on
IG for our streets on making is a bit
weak and okay I was thinking to take in
656 bomb and then I said okay if I take
on is six if they mattify 26 like what I
played I said I thought that 57 is
lumber because I can take okie five but
of course when he played the 27 I found
that rope if I was losing immediately
are gonna squinty one okay then I had to
sacrifice my queen nuts can I jump in
absolutely Robert take it away it's
awesome this is Grand Master Robert leg
a ski we've been following your game
very exciting stuff now I I'm aware that
you're a bit of an expert in the Kings
Indian attack so I wanted to ask you if
you were familiar with this h6 g5 pawn
sacrifice because my understanding is
that usually white tries to avoid
playing efile until black has castle of
King side and that's correct and here it
seems like your opponent played quite
well because he didn't castle too
quickly and then he was happy to trade
his Jeep on for your ePHI pawn
was this
this sacrifice actually is always
working when black already gossip so
it's always interesting because he's
kingside this week and be sure before is
full of usually by Bishop b4 and finish
fine stuff like that so my attack is
very tender but now he didn't test it so
I thought this could still work but okay
maybe I'm so 25 I could play my teat 94
month instead of D D for which is bad I
think this should be over 94 could maybe
gift still has some compensation because
it's not easy for him to do castle short
or long right my not one G for giving me
something position because if seven
point and if you can't cast it and I
always have some tricks on 97 or 96 and
24 okay I think I have compensation yeah
initial idea but then I saw the e4 and I
totally forgot I can take on g5 you know
I thought you have to play 23 or 24 sand
I move Queen g4 and Bishop f1 Street -
you know okay also 24 I have 96th Street
so I thought it's good but I totally
forgot you can take on g5 and after 25 I
think it's just piss off yeah well
definitely a good defensive effort on
your part we were pretty much writing
you off as losing that endgame but then
you got that fortress and and came away
with a very important half point so
congratulations
thank you if possible how would you
evaluate your performance in the
tournament thus far my best day okay
good she's a very strong player and yeah
I think I had a slightly better ending
but ok when we both entered were playing
going increment I think we was had
missed some chances to win ok it was
normal to London okay the third round of
course I think and I was just close
things off but ok I still hold back and
sacrifice the Queen and again yeah it
seems I'm sacrificing a lot of Queens
so yeah I was happy to not lose the
third round yesterday I think today
first two rounded plate decent games and
I won't
okay last round okay maybe I took so
much risk but still I think I put back
Weyland okay not to lose such a position
is of course good news for me
so bossom I'm hoping that you can clear
this this doubt that we have so it's
it's how do shake or a douche how do you
pronounce I'm embarrassed to ask him so
I'm gonna ask you that way we want to
talk to him we don't you know I do you
were right I corrected you yes all right
thank you all right about someone last
thing you're coming into this tournament
a couple hundred points higher rated to
the next guy
do you feel any additional pressure for
this tournament because of that compared
to others
yeah of course you know when you are
favorite and everybody is expecting you
to believe every single game you know
which is not easy against a strong field
also I would like to mention that all
African pairs are way underrated because
they don't just play you know classical
tournaments mm-hmm so yeah I think the
rating gap is it's just not not serene
because I think most of them you know I
could be at least hundred points more so
yeah and it's okay rapid in which format
also anything could happen you know just
longer one move introduced again so yeah
it's not easy but okay I'm trying my
best and okay still one more rapid day
and took these days to go on I hope I
come true
that was an excellent point about the
the ratings gap thank you for bringing
that up
well we'll let you get some rest thank
you for joining us Bassam and good luck
tomorrow thanks a lot good luck a lot of
people there that's something a lot of
people don't think about it it's there
are pockets of people in different age
groups in geographical groups around the
world that don't play in the
tournaments that people around here do
in st. Louis say yeah that's true and
generally speaking young players are
usually underrated because they're
studying and playing the whole time and
it takes time for that rating to catch
up with them so anyone that's constantly
working on their chests you're gonna
find that they're underrated now if you
don't have access to tournaments that
just makes that underrated even more
pronounced because you just don't have
opportunities to let that rating catch
up with you so yeah I absolutely agree
I'm from what we've seen I mean we're
talking about like twenty to twenty
three hundred rated players that are
pushing a twenty seven hundred to the
limits so that says something right
there's some science behind it is there
we're seeing it with in front of our
eyes okay I see I see the magic this the
magics happening it is happening so
while you're standing by to see if we're
gonna get anyone else perhaps not today
let's take a look at the standings after
six rapid rounds have been completed now
you will see it's not settled yet three
players with nine points at the top
we're still in the stage of the game
where all the games are worth two points
the blitz on Friday and I'm pardon me
the bullets on Saturday and Sunday will
be worth just one point so it's
important to establish dominance at this
stage in the game thoughts on what
you've seen so far Robert well I think
today was a big day for Boston because
not only did he win a couple of nice
games but he drew a completely hopeless
position and that can give you that you
know sort of boost in your morale that
you need to really go all the way in a
tournament whenever you see somebody win
a tournament you hear this thing called
they know champions luck or winners
lucky and it's not like you won because
you were lucky but you were lucky at a
critical point and that was the turning
point you know that's where you're like
clicked and everything started going
your way and you get the
confidence to really trust your moves
and not waste any opportunities so I
think this is probably the most
important game of bassam's that we've
seen awesome Amin versus no clue salad
Nani
yeah the drug yeah a draw because is
Nani one of the leaders as well I think
I saw him up there and this week is it
possible bring the standings because
this game puts them
I think tied with the same amount of
points and there we see yeah one of the
leaders so this was a huge game because
if Ella Nani had won he would have left
bossom trailing and he would have seized
the lead as well it's clear first yes
yeah absolutely and considering this is
the rapid portion it's particularly
important because then when the Blitz
comes okay it's not weighted as heavily
yeah it's still not on the board yeah I
mean that's very surprising I think
probably the most surprising thing of
the tournament that a grandmaster of
slim bel ho Diaz trajectory is having
such a hard time and today he was
actually completely winning I mean do we
have time to pull up that yeah sure yep
he had played a great game let's see it
wasn't round six it was against Andrew
CAI own day so let me just be round five
I believe round five okay that makes
sense
yeah so let's see
yeah here's the game look at this
bill hoodie is playing black and he's
got this tremendous pawn I need to and
all of a sudden white plays this tactic
Queen takes c8 King takes c8 h7 and I
mean this looks devastating looks like
we don't have enough time to Queen
because now white also Queens and after
Queen b8 for example I think at the very
least white is gonna win our queen and
enter a queen and pawn endgame where
whites just up two pawns and one of
these is probably gonna queen so when I
first saw this I was like Oh win for
white but all of a sudden black has this
queen h6 but the Queen swings over to
the other side of the board and if you
go check King c7 h8 I can just give up
this Queen and use this e to pawn and
pretty much seal the deal although as
we've seen you know Queen against rook
might not seal the deal at all I mean we
saw him the Amin game just now the
things in rapid and especially in blitz
anything can happen but in this game
instead of going Queen h6 black lady won
Queen and after h8 well I think the game
just ended after h8 Queen because black
figured after Queen da trick g8 and
after king c7 I think there's a mating
attack here rook takes f7 king c6 I
don't know if there's mate but at the
very least we can always gain this Queen
and enter completely winning a game so
that I don't think chess is the problem
here there's a an element of bad luck as
well and maybe time pressure and when
you combine bad luck and time pressure
you get you know dangerous cocktail
oddly enough I don't even think we
mentioned it when we saw the standings
earlier the three players tied for with
9 points
very top are the top seeds really or
three top seeds yeah oh I didn't notice
that so yeah we're talking about a amine
a douche and elet Nani so in a way
unpredictable in a way pretty in every
way I mean yeah it's not like we have
these column gains that you know get
crazy as we enter time trouble and then
you know there's blunders I mean the
games are crazy right out of the gate I
mean today was the first you know quick
draw we saw with that move repetition
but otherwise all the games are chaotic
right well that'll do it for today for
day number two of the 2018 cote d'ivoire
rapid and blitz invitational this we'll
be back with you tomorrow
at the same time right here on chest 24
calm and on chest bass and remember the
rounds begin earlier than our broadcast
does so if you're watching in the States
the rounds will begin at 10 a.m. Central
Time
that's 3 p.m. in on the Ivory Coast and
we'll be on the air with you starting at
12:45 p.m. Central Time 17:45 UTC so be
sure to check in this is the last day
rapid round three tomorrow it's the last
day for the rapids and it's the last day
that we start at this time so stay tuned
and we'll have more information with you
as we get closer so this event was
produced by the world's greatest
production B team Tammy Hyde is the
technical adviser Isaac's France is on
graphics and audio the technical
director is Dennis LaRue I'm Ben Simon
I'm Robert Han gaskey it's been a
pleasure
yeah and until tomorrow we say so long
from the show-me-state
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you